Speaker 1: Let's go next to ya'll from
Ontario, Canada, ya'll. You were on the air.
Can you hear me, I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: I've never had a chance to be
on the show. Was great. I wanted to ask a couple
of questions. First, with the Democratic Party,
just for the State of the Union address, the other
day, I saw the polls after the. After the address,
and it showed that most Democrats weren't really
favorable, as Biden's address mostly focused on
foreign policy and not inflation or the economy.
Why are the Democrats so poor at addressing
issues that are very important to the American
people? And should they be looking to push people
like Joe Manchin out of the party because it
seems like they're afraid to offend people and
instead of standing strong for certain topics?
Speaker 1: Well, first of all, I don't know
that I agree with the premise from from what I'm
seeing. A CBS News poll found that 78 percent of
Americans approved of the speech either somewhat
or strongly so. I guess the first thing is I
don't know that we're working with the same
information. I didn't see this negative response.
Speaker 3: This was the polls right
out on CNN right after the State
of the Union. And oh, are you saying
Speaker 1: like on the website of CNN?
Speaker 3: This is I was watching CNN do an
analysis right after the State of the Union
address. Yeah. And I just went in. It just went
to show that I believe sixty eight percent showed
they were favorable toward Joe Biden's speech on
foreign policy toward the Ukraine address. Yeah,
and it showed that 48 percent were satisfied
with his questioning on or on his address toward
the economy and inflation.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK, so that was
like a topic by topic. Well, listen, I don't know.
I didn't see that data and a lot of times in the
aftermath of these speeches, these are like
very informal, like it's just who the people
that vote on our website, too. Usually, it takes
a while to get something a little more formal.
I mean, I think so. I'm not sure about that.
I think that in terms of you're saying,
why? Why aren't Democrats good at addressing
issues in a way that people that resonates with
people? Is that generally what you're asking?
Speaker 3: Yeah, because it just seems like you
have such a wide fact based factions in the
Democratic Party. It just seems like someone
like Joe Manchin as an example doesn't
seem like he wants to play ball with the
Democrats are trying to do any meaningful
policy pass. So instead of trying to
appeal to him, why don't they
just try to either primary him or?
Try in a way to like how the Democratic
Party stand for something that's solid,
it doesn't seem like people really believe the
Democratic Party stands for anything or stands by
an ending strongly that the Republican Party does.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I don't know that I exactly
understand the question you're asking. But I mean,
I think on Joe Manchin, as I've said before, if
you successfully primary choma Joe Manchin, that
almost certainly gets flipped and it becomes a
Republican seat. I believe the solution is you've
got to flip Republican seats, you've got to flip
Republican seats so that Joe Manchin doesn't have
as much power and the viability of doing that
this November in what are going to be probably
tough midterms for Democrats is a real question
mark. But in terms of the messaging piece and
what the Republican Party says, the Democrat
Democratic Party stands for versus what the
Democratic Party actually says that it stands for.
I have so many different clips about
this, and part of this is messaging.
Part of this is not wanting to turn people off.
You don't want to. You don't want to offend
any slice of your party, which is impossible
if you have anything beyond an extremely
narrow coalition. So this is a long issue for
Democrats, and I've spoken extensively about it,
but I don't think the solution to all of this is
you primary Manchin. I think that that one could
backfire and two is it's too narrow a solution.
Speaker 3: OK, and can I have one more question?
Just Russia-Ukraine? How much do you think this
is actually a failure of American foreign policy
like long term?
Speaker 1:
Are you saying how much is how much is American
foreign policy a cause of what's happening?
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's what I meant. Yes.
Speaker 1: Long term, I think that it is.
I mean, the reason this is so tough is. In a
globalized, dynamic and complex world, we can't
make a statement like nothing the U.S. has ever
done is related to Putin. Invading Ukraine like
that would be that that would be wrong. Obviously,
Ukraine and Russia exist on a planet where the
U.S. has significant influence. But I think we
have to be really careful when we talk about bla